LDN  RHAINTHW  FOOTAGE OF WHAT
OUT,D OUD SHAKHMUTIT IS JUST AOH
OF A CITY.
SOMEMAT WE IERRAL TIMEONOUTFRONO
ENT THAT H F
I WANT TO WARN YOU THAWHO SE GRC
T US TO GO
IT'S AAI SOLERT
HAS BEENY WOUNDE AN PLOSIOLIFE-
SHARE . TRSOLDIELY, THIS SOLSUIT
E
NICK PATAL IS "O  SOUTHERN UKRAT
WHERE FOURSDAY ALON
COTA MEAN AND VE.LE JUST  THE
HERE CARRYIN
SPST.Y NO FEA
TIMEAS DUSFA THE SKY IS LI
ALL THEY C DST
ALIVE D THHATH OCCUPIED AREAK
EARLIESO MUCT AL VERY
CLOFTEN JARRING.
WE HEAR A JET OVERHEAD, TH
SLOWLY BUILDING SOUNOF DAMAGE
VI TOWAR Y.
A A HALF-MILLION-DOLLAR
ANDS.
ANOTHEAST FOLLOWS.
THSY OF ION,
AIR.
ONE.
DO H CAN GET AW MASSELY BRUTAL
RUSSIAN FIRE.M GNAT.
I CAN STILL SMELTHOSIVE
MILITARY TARGET IS.
AT THE E ROAD IS
A HAS SAID I
IS EVACUAT JUSM
IAT LINE
HERE, A WORLS RIESHOLD
BACK.
THEY'RE GOIN B
THE UKRAI FFENSIVE. TOWN REALL.
AND SO FEWE
LITTLE NEED  EVACUATE.
PE TRYING TO
INSTT.N OFFIE -ENGLISH ] IDEPEA
POTENTIALLWHE Y ALS,LIANS MOSTLE
LA ITSOUNTEROFFENSIVE.UKY THAT'A
.EAVING IT RECENTLY., THOUGH, M
BUT TOMORROW WL D IN MOSCO
TENDS  MARIES WITH
D TO CREAT>>IGHT NOW TO
D AR LIEUTENANT
NEG.PART OF WHAT TALKING
ZAZH ,AC00M THLIN
TONIGHT DUE TO
HAS BEEN S TARGEOSTO TRANSPORTA
LIKELY IN THE  UKRAINIAN  THINK
HUNDRE
O MISTAKE.
RUT EVACUATING THESE
PEOPLE FN NGS ZENS AWAY SOT THET
HELP TOMING UKRAINIAN
MI
ITTHE NA
DID IN FE ER KILLED
RESIST FIGHTERS,D  AWAY SO THAT
Y.NG IN TO FRANCE
WHAT THEY'RE
THEY'R THEPOPULATION SP
D SPOT WHEARE.
THELINIA
FO WHERE THE DEFSI
EY CAN'TOIR
SO T AD OF
THAT ARE GOING ON RIGHNOW.>> I B
CL
HUT.ING I WANTED
HE HHE
ROUP, ISHIS
TR GETTING AMMUNITION, Y'RENG I
THE REASON I'M MENTIONING THIS I
TO PULL ALOF HISOUT OFASNG
KHAD NO
SUPPORT,
NOTHING OM
MILITARY.
ID INT T IS SUDDEN THEY'RE G AM
AN KREMLINPOLITIBA FORTH
LEADER OF
E N TERSMOSTING THING IS THIS
HABEFUNCTION NOW FOR MO
THESE KINDON
T PLAYE EVE
OF UKRAINIAN
FORCES, THEY'RE STILL SCREWIT
WHO'S IN CHARGE AND WHTH
LEADER I